Research on the structure of operating systems in the mid' 90s, as exemplified
by the three research papers we studied in this course module, led to
fascinating innovations in the operating system
structure. It is important to note that
all three systems, Spen, exokernel, and the
LT microkernel were done contemporaneously. In this
sense, they mutually informed each other
and laid the basis for several innovations
in operating system structuring. For example,
many modern operating systems have internally adopted
a microkernel based design. Similarly, technologies
such as dynamic loading of device drivers
into the kernel, have come out of the thoughts that went into extensibility
of operating system services. The next lesson we're going to look at is a
logical progression of the idea of extensibility, namely virtualization.